à l'issue du premier tour aux
clayes-sous-bois quatre candidats
étaient susceptibles de se maintenir
pour le second tour
finalement stéphanie jamin se retirer ce
sera une triangulaire avec une seule
liste de gauche celle de nicolas u qui
sera opposé à philipp guiguen et
anne-claire frémont sur la liste de
cette dernière figure la maire sortante
véronique côté millard qui entre-temps a
préféré soutenir son premier adjoint
philippe kigen à guyancourt quatre
candidats étaient en ballotage à l'issue
du premier tour
pour ce second tour la liste d'olivier
paréja fusionne avec celle du maire
sortant françois morton l'aiguillon
courtois auront donc le choix entre
trois listes françois morton rodolphe
baril et grégory pape
pas de surprise à plaisir les trois
listes arrivées en tête lors du premier
tour se maintiennent pour le scrutin du
28 juin la liste de la maire sortante
joséphine coleman berger sera opposée
aux listes de patrick jean terre et
annie joël prio hasseni pour ce second
tour il n'y aura pas d'alliance attrape
ce sera une triangulaire avec la liste
du maire sortant guy malandain celle de
son ancien adjoint à lire à b enfin la
liste du conseiller municipal
d'opposition othman nasri ouf à la
verrière sur les quatre listes du
premier tour trois sont en lice pour le
28 juin prochain
celle de la maire sortante nelly duthu
la liste de son premier adjoint jean
yves blé et celle du conseiller
municipal d'opposition nicolas dainville
surprise en revanche à villepreux avec
une fusion de listes celle de valérie
ban arrivé en seconde position lors du
premier tour et celle de sylvie sva
ont-elles arrivé quatrième
il y aura donc une triangulaire à
villepreux avec le maire sortant
stéphane mirambeau valérie bain et jean
baptiste à monique 3 c'est également le
nombre de listes pour le second tour à
voisins le bretonneux des listes
identique à celle du 15 mars dernier
celle de la maire sortante
alexandra rosetti celle d'olivier à
france ô et de béatrice pierrât